un accès au public au palais
présidentiel d'Ankara inhabituel tout
autant que sa victoire est historique a
dit le président erdan c'est un nouveau
siècle qui s'ouvre pour la Turquie
moderne déjà bientôt centenaire a-t-il
lancé à la foule il a plein pouvoir il a
le Parlement il est président avec un
dresscore il a montré au monde surtout
que il y a pas de dictature en Turquie
il y a une vraie démocratie patrick et
son frère deux franco-turques sont venus
de Paris pour voter ils sont restés pour
savourer la victoire
[Musique]
la répression et l'érosion des libertés
la réponse tardive du gouvernement au
tremblement de terre meurtrier de
février une crise économique brutale
rien de tout ça n'a suffit à briser le
lien entre le président erdan et ses
électeurs pour Patrick c'est
l'opposition et l'Occident qui cherchait
à mettre la Turquie à genoux il savait
très bien que c'était l'économie le
point faible ils ont tout fait pour que
le pays s'écroule mais ça va fonctionner
aujourd'hui personne n'a perdu 85
millions sont ensemble victorieux nous
ne ressentons pas de colère ou de rage
envers qui que ce soit le radis le
président
Erdogan
[Applaudissements]
dans son discours de victoire cette nuit
le président Ardon parlait du besoin
d'unifier la population du pays les
tensions dans les rues d'Ankara
aujourd'hui sont très palpables
a peut-être gagné les Arabes ont
peut-être gagné avec le Qatar mais le
peuple turc lui a définitivement perdu
nous avons perdu au moins le siècle à
venir confiait à Lille
notre conversation il évite devenu
évident que personne n'est vraiment prêt
à mettre de côté les affrontements comme
disait le souhaiter le président de Anne
quelques heures plus tôt
parlant son nom à des étrangers surtout
pour exprimer des opinions contraires au
siennes lui qui a voté pour le président
erdan
depuis des décennies 17 analyste
politique la division de l'électorat
n'est pas nouvelle mais ce qui a changé
c'est que le position n'est plus divisé
cette union de l'opposition la remplit
difficile à ignorer Croatie mais il ne
faut pas attendre de changement dans la
politique autoritaire du président
erdohan pas plus qu'il ne devrait
transformer sa politique étrangère
c'est un allié difficile mais qui ne
l'est pas de nos jours les alliances ne
sont plus qu'elles étaient elles ne sont
plus cool dit-il le monde est devenu
plus transactionnel et hardwan c'est le
maître de la transaction c'est pour ça
qu'il est difficile et qu'il va demeurer
un allié difficile
l'Europe est contre lui on le voit dans
les
journaux les États-Unis Biden
la Turquie d'abord une grande Turquie
c'est ce qu'il célèbre aujourd'hui alors
ce ne sont pas ces électeurs qui
risquent de lui en tenir rigueur ici
marie-eveda Radio-Canada Ankara